من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام في
الوسط انسرات المغازي وايضا البريج وجنوبا
خانيونس كانت العناوين العريضه للاستهداف
الاسرائيليه كيف تبدو وتيره الاستهدافات
وايضا ضعنا في صوره
اثارها الاستهدافات بتت مكثفه في وسط قطاع
غزه لا سما في المخيمات التي تقع في شرق
شارع صلاح الدين وهي مخيمات مخيم البريج
وايضا مخيم المغازي ومنطقه جحر الديك وهذه
المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه في كل لحظه وفي كل حين ويسمع
ما بين الفينه والاخرى اصوات الانفجارات
الناجمه عن اطلاق المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
لهذه القذائف باتجاه المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه وباتجاه المناطق المفتوحه في
تلك المنطقه الدبابات الاسرائيليه توغلت
لعده مئات من الا الامتار باتجاه المناطق
الماهوله وقلب مخيم البريج وحتى الان ما
زالت القذائف تسقط باتجاه هذه المناطق
وبالتالي هناك اعداد من الاصابات واعداد
حتى من الشهداء لم تستطع طواقم الاسعاف
الوصول اليها في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي لهذه المناطق ايضا الغارات
الجويه لم تتوقف ربما تنخفض حدتها في
ساعات الصباح لكنها منذ فجر هذا اليوم
كانت عنيفه جدا باتجاه هذه المناطق وكانت
مركزه في مناطق وسط القطاع قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منزلا في دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه وكان هناك عدد من الشهداء
منزلا في منطقه الزوايده وكان هناك عدد من
الشهداء ايضا في مخيم النصيرات كان هناك
منزل وكان هناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
ووصلت اعداد الشهداء والجرحى الى 17 شهيدا
من جراء هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه على هذه
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه وعندما نتحدث
عن منازل مدنيه فاننا نتحدث عن منازل
ماهوله بالسكان قصفتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بدون اي سابق انذار وهذه
المناز نازل لا يتواجد فيها فقط افراد هذه
العائله بل هناك عشرات من النازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين هربوا من الحمم القصف
الاسرائيليه في مناطق مختلفه ولجوا الى
هذه المنازل في وسط القطاع على اساس انها
امنه بعد ان تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
مناطق وسط القطاع او مناطق جنوب الوادي هي
مناطق امنه لكنه عاد ليقص فها وعاد وعاد
ليطلب من السكان الخروج من بعض هذه
المناطق بالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي ربما
خلال هذه الايام بات مركزا على مناطق وسط
قطاع غزه بالاضافه بكل تاكيد الى المناطق
الاخرى كمدينه غزه وجباليا ومناطق مدينه
خانيونس لا سما المناطق الشرقيه ا هشام
وانت تتحدث الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
خبر عاجل يعلن سقوط ثمانيه شهداء وعدد من
الجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي قرب مستشفى الامل
التابع للجمعيه في خانيونس تحديدا وهذا
ايضا نمط بات معتادا فيما يتعلق باستهداف
المستشفيات او محيط
هشام بالفعل هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يقصف فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي مستشفى الامل
وهو ليس عباره عن مستشفى فقط هو ايضا مركز
للايواء وهناك عشرات بل مئات من النازحين
الفلسطينيين يتواجدون داخل هذا المستشفى
بقبل يومين قصف الطابق الرابع في في
المركز التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وهو مركز ايواء واصيب واستشهد عدد من
الفلسطينيين قصف محيطه وايضا عندما نتحدث
عن هذا المركز فهو يقع ايضا في حي الامل
وهو في قلب مدينه خانيونس وهو وهو احد
المناطق المكتظه بل المليئه بالسكان
والنازحين الفلسطينيين نحن نتحدث عن مدينه
خانيونس التي تقع جنوب الوادي ايضا التي
طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من السكان اللجوء
اليها او النزوح اليها ولكن هو الان يعود
لقصف هذه المناطق وجزء اساسي من عمليات
القصف هي في وسط مدينه خانيونس لا سما حي
الامل الان من جديد يعود لاستهداف هذه
المستشفى وهذا المركز التابع للهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني الذي يتواجد فيه نازحون
والذي ايضا قصف على مبنى هذا ال على على
سطح هذا المبنى المركزيه الخاصه
بالاتصالات بالهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وقطع
الاتصالات وبالتالي هناك ازمه كبيره من
جراء هذه عمليه القصف لان الناس وسيارات
الاسعاف باتت لا تستطيع التواصل مع بعضها
البعض نشكرك من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زق